Calcula la pendiente de la línea que pasa
por los puntos 7, -1 y -3, -1.
Por acá voy a hacer una gráfica para poder
visualizar donde están estos puntos y por
donde pasa la línea recta.
así que déjenme dibujo aquí mis ejes,
ahí están...
Y bueno nuestro primer
punto  es el 7, -1,
así que 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, en mi eje "x" y -1 en
la dirección "y", ahí está, el 7, -1.
Este es mi eje "y", claro.
Y mi segundo punto es el -3, -1, así que
me voy 3 unidades a la izquierda,
retrocedo 3 unidades y mi coordenada
"y" es de nuevo -1, ahí está.
Y la línea que conecta estos dos puntos,
se ve algo así...
ahí más o menos...
El ejercicio nos pide encontrar la pendiente
de la línea que pasa por estos dos puntos,
es decir, de esta línea de aquí.
Intuitivamente, la pendiente es una medida
de lo inclinada que está una recta,
aunque más formalmente la pendiente está definida
como el alza entre el avance
o lo que es lo mismo el cambio
en "y" entre el cambio en "x"
y en algunos casos, la pendiente aparece denotada por la letra "m",
el cambio en "y"aparece como "y2" que es
la coordenada "y" del segundo punto
menos la coordenada "y" del primer punto, "y1".
Dividido entre el cambio en "x", que es "x2" menos "x1".
En realidad todas estas fórmulas son expresiones
distintas de la misma cosa.
Y el significado de la pendiente es el siguiente,
si me alzo mucho en dirección "y" al avanzar
poco en dirección "x", pendiente va a ser
un número muy grande, si por el contrario,
me alzo poco en relación a un avance en "x",
entonces la pendiente es un número chico,
que es más o menos lo que sucede aquí.
En general, podríamos emplear cualquiera
de los dos puntos como nuestro punto inicial,
pero en este caso vamos a empezar en el -3, -1.
Así que me voy a mover del -3, -1 al 7, -1.
Mi coordenada "x" empieza siendo -3 y termina
siendo 7 positivo por acá, así que hay un
así que hay un cambio de 10 unidades.
Se mueve desde el -3 al 7,
entonces mi cambio en "x"es 10.
¿Y cuánto es mi cambio en "y"?
Pues acá vale -1, pero acá también vale
-1,
así que realmente no cambié en la dirección "y",
mi cambio en "y"vale 0.
Así que en este caso el alza es 0, no importa
cuánto me mueva, mi "y" se mantiene igual.
Para calcular la pendiente, divido el alza
entre el avance,
nuestro avance fue de 10 unidades.
Muy bien, y para es cambio en "x",
¿cuánto vale mi alza?
Pues mi alza vale 0, así que la pendiente es 0.
Otra forma de pensarlo es que esta línea
no tiene inclinación, es completamente horizontal,
así que en este caso, la pendiente es 0.
Bien y ahora vamos a ver que esto coincide
con todas las fórmulas.
Recuerden que todas las fórmulas equivalen
a el alza entre el avance o lo que es lo mismo,
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Lo importante es que todas son una medida
de que tan inclinada está una línea recta.
Pero bueno, si empleamos la fórmula... la
pendiente "m" tomando el 7, -1 como nuestro
punto inicial y el -3, -1 como nuestro punto
final y en este caso "x1" es 7, "y1" es -1,
-3 sería "x2" y -1 sería "y2", así que este es nuestro punto inicial y este es nuestro punto final.
Así es que la pendiente vale el cambio en
"y", que es "y2" menos "y1" que es -1 menos
-1, dividido entre "x2" que es -3 menos "x1"
que es 7, así es que tengo -1 menos -1,
que es -1 más 1dividido entre -3
menos 7 que es -10.
Y de nuevo, esto nos da 0 entre -10 que ya
sabemos que nos da 0.
La razón para que aquí aparezca un -10 y
acá un 10 positivo, se debe a que intercambiamos
nuestro punto de inicio y nuestro punto final,
es decir, aquí habíamos empezado en el -3, -1
y nos habíamos movido al 7, -1, en el
segundo ejemplo,
lo que hicimos fue empezar en el 7, -1
y movernos al -3, -1.
Entonces en este caso, en el segundo ejemplo,
nuestro cambio en "x"
es negativo porque nos movemos a la izquierda,
pero nuestro cambio en "y" sigue siendo 0.
Así que el valor de la pendiente es 0, pues
es una línea horizontal.